hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up well I have thousands of
crabs and lobsters been washing up dead
on beaches on England's Northeast Coast
we hear about the row that's been
brewing between governments
campaigners and local fishermen
the world's Elite is gathering in Davos
for the first day of the world economic
Forum with debate over green subsidies
top of the agenda
and British gas announces plans to
provide heat pumps for as low as 3 000
pounds in a bid to help households shift
away from gas boilers
[Music]
foreign
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now arau has broken out between
government campaigners and local
fishermen as thousands of dead crabs and
lobsters have been washing up on beaches
across Seaside and North Yorkshire since
2021. campaigners and fishermen blamed
the dredging of the historically
industrial River teas for releasing a
chemical that is toxic to shellfish
well in September last year dredging was
undertaken to deepen a new key for the
building of the t-side Freeport a key
part of the government's leveling up
agenda
the government blamed an algal bloom for
the die-offs but independent scientists
blamed the dredging a new report looking
at the evidences due to report back this
month Skies Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark sent us this from the
tease estuary
speak to fishermen here in the teas
Estuary they'll tell you they're in the
middle of an ongoing environmental
disaster they haven't caught any crabs
or lobsters since about Autumn of 2021
when there was a mass mortality event
thousands of dead crabs and lobsters
being washed up on the beaches around
here an investigation by defra concluded
that an algal bloom of toxic algae was
the most likely cause but since then
independent scientists have come up with
an alternative explanation that it's
actually toxic sediment that's been
dredged from the tea zestri and dumped a
few miles offshore that has been the
cause of those die-offs and there's more
evidence for that they saying that those
die-offs have been continuing
documents that have been seen by Sky
News suggest more than 50 reports of
marine life being washed up dead or
dying and on top of that dredging
activity and we've just seen some of it
is continuing to go on in the tea zestri
party for the development of the new
Freeport here
now in response to pressure from
campaigners at MPS defra has assembled
an independent expert panel to review
the potential causes and that's expected
to report later this month
now if it finds that toxic sediments
could have been the cause of this
die-off that will raise important
questions about whether that risk should
have been known about before because
this area has been known to be
contaminated for quite a long time and
also raises questions about how ongoing
development can hear can continue here
safely without causing further damage to
the environment
Tom Clark bear well let's take a look at
some of the other stories making the
news today for you and the government is
proposing to introduce new measures
designed to protect important Marine
habitats from harmful fishing methods it
says it is Consulting on restrictions to
the use of the so-called bottom-toed
gear whereby netsar drags along the
ocean floor by fishing trawlers the
plans mean that 40 of England's Marine
protected areas could benefit from
greater protection by 2024.
more than 100 beds have been received in
the UK's latest round of offshore oil
and gas licensing the bids will now be
studied and those that go ahead could
begin production in as little as 18
months campaigners have criticized the
government for issuing new oil and gas
licenses which they say isn't compatible
with the UK's Net Zero commitments but
the government says it is committed to
securing more domestic energy supplies
Britain's largest household energy
supplier is hoping to help home
homeowners lower their emissions by
making it cheaper to switch from gas
boilers to heat pumps British gas is
offering prices from 3 000 pounds and
will price match any offer by a rival
company well unlike gas boilers heat
pumps warm homes entirely from the
electricity grid without any carbon
emissions in the process so they're
widely seen as a key technology to shift
British homes away from fossil fueled
Heating
electric vehicle users could save up to
a thousand pounds a year while lowering
their carbon footprint under a new
government plan aimed at making smart
charging more accessible 16 million
pounds will be spent to boost the
network of units with smart charging
capabilities which encourage charging
when electricity is cheaper cleaner and
in less demand to reduce pressure on the
grid
and hundreds of Staff working at British
vaults have been made redundant after
the company failed to secure a buyer the
batteries startup has fallen into
Administration today following talks
with investors over a possible sale to
keep the firm afloat the company was hit
by a delay to prompt a promised
Government funding to build a planned
battery gigafactory
now the world economic Forum has begun
in Switzerland with world leaders
meeting in person for the first time in
two years for the annual gathering in
Davos financing for climate action has
been at the top of the agenda for some
of the forums events on day one already
as well as green subsidies
now the European commission president
Ursula vonzalein outlined her plans for
a green deal industrial plan to make it
easier to push through subsidies for
green Industries as part of the eu's
ambition to become Net Zero by 2050.
climate change already
comes with a huge cost
and we have no time to lose in the
transition to a clean economy the new
net zero industry Act
will identify clear goals
for European clean tech by 2030
the aim will be to focus investment on
strategic projects along the entire
supply chain
we will especially look at how to
simplify and Fast Track the permitting
process for clean tech production sites
or meanwhile climate Finance has been a
hot topic of discussion elsewhere at the
conference Brazil's environment Minister
Marina Silva said promised International
Investments to help reduce the
deforestation of the Amazon have not
materialized while the U.S climate Envoy
told a panel that not enough private
investment is going towards climate
action well during a panel at The Forum
John Kerry urged philanthropists to
contribute more towards decarbonisation
well the lesson I've learned in the last
years
and I learned it as secretary and I've
learned it since reinforced in Spades is
money money money money money money
money money money money
and I'm sorry to say that I mean yes
technology yes exciting new initiatives
yes organizing winning races politically
I mean what happened uh in in the
midterms in the United States is nothing
less than miraculous it happened because
young people voted
and the second most voted issue was
climate
it's a huge deal
but we have to go further
that's all for today we're back tomorrow
do join us then bye-bye
[Music]